Hey, how's it goin', bros? My name is PewDiePie!
Today is a very… Special… Day. Lemme tell you why.
We're playing Mirror's Edge™ 2
or Cataclyst…?
Catalyst.
Whatever, no one cares.
Mirror's Edge™ 2. I'll just call it that.
Uh, a lot of people don't know this,
but Mirror's Edge™ was one of the first games
I ever recorded for my YouTube channel.
It was on my first channel, which
was YouTube.com/PewDie
which I forgot the password to
and created PewDiePie. So I
used to upload videos playing that game and
I remember people were just obsessed with this game.
They wanted a sequel and here we
are, six– What is it? Six
years later? We finally got one.
Uh, I don't know why it took them so
long, but… For me
Mirror's Edge™ is an amazing game
because of the gameplay. DICE™,
the company that made this game, they really do first
person experiences better than no other,
and uh,
a lot of games…
do it these days, but back in the day,
what they did with Mirror's Edge™ was
uh, was really innovative and really
uh… Pushing– Pushing
uh, new limits and
I, uh, I'm curious to see if they're
gonna do the same with this title. The only
thing that was really bad about the first game was the
story, and it looks like they're trying to tell
a better story this time, so… I'm really
excited to go on a new adventure with you bros! Especially
a game that I have a personal
uh, connection to, I guess you can
say and– and to share that online with
y'all, I think is really cool.
And I'm really excited to do this.
Uh… To play one of the games
that I started playing.
Will it be good? I sure
hope so. I'm playing with the Xbox controller
uh, because I only got a
copy for the Xbox.
And the game isn't out yet,
but I'll probably be switching to PC
as soon as I can
because this feels a little weird. Uh…
"In the city of glass, the Conglomerate
rules supreme. All regular
citizens have been made willing
slaves, lured into
an endless race for status and wealth."
So I think it's a little bit like, um…
The story is a little bit like 1984™,
the government has taken over–
"But some choose to live off the Grid."
The runners live off the Grid.
"The runners work as couriers
and cat burglars. The rooftops
belong to them. As long as they don't
openly challenge the authorities,
the Conglomerate turns a blind eye."
So they basically are like messengers…
And they– They do all this parkour
shit. "For almost two decades
the status quo has held."
I remember like six years
ago, parkour was actually cool, but
now, it's just like, stupid.
"Times are about to change."
Aw, she's so cute! Oh my god!
So Faith, the main
character, her family died
by the government during a protest.
And then
Faith was like,
"I'm gonna get a bunch of"– Oh, there we go… WI'm gonna
get a bunch of tattoos now."
I'll tell you all about the story in the first game
You don't have to worry about that. But
I'll try and not babble too much 'cause I can go on a lot about
this game.
Are we in prison?
Why is she doin' that?
Did she get brainwashed?
What did they do to you, Faith?
Yep.
Alright, alright, alright.
"Leech"?
Ooh…
What a dick!
What did we do?
Twelve months.
That's a cool helmet.
Who's her stylist in prison?
Her hair looks on point.
Yeah, yeah, yeah…
That's– Ooh, I like her voice…
Uh, this is weird. We didn't see Faith much
at all in the first game.
Barely anything, 'cause all the…
She was only anima–There was– The story was
told through really shitty animation. They looked like
tampon commercials.
It was fucking embarrassing.
Uh…
I don't know if I like this or not.
I wish they told the story through first person insead.
Yeah…
Shut up…
Bitch.
Um…
Kinda like Half-Life®…
'Cause…
But, I guess they wanna…
market it as some kind of movie
'cause that's what games does these days.
Alright, we're free!
♪ 'Cause I'm free ♪
Can't see anything.
I think there's a glitch here.
Yes, definitely a glitch. What the fuck?
Alright, I'm playing an early version of the game… God dammit…
Please, please…
Oh– it works. Okay, here we go.
We got a bracelet. No, it's–
Fucking glitches! Fuck…
Okay. It might work.
It might work. I would– I would stay
around and look, but I think it's working.
Guys, I gotta disclosure, this is an
early version of the game.
I'm sure this is gonna be fixed.
Uh, fuck, I just wanna play.
It looks awesome.
I think.
I hope.
What I loved about the first game was how bright
it was and how beautiful.
It's very unlike Mirror's Edge™ to start the
game like this.
Hey, buddy.
So, if you played the first game, you know to always
follow the red.
Thanks, Icarus.
Cool glasses, dude.
And it's red.
See, I like this better if they do the cutscenes
like this. It's more interesting.
Alright, so I just put a chip next to my face.
Eh, very 80s, what the fuck is this?
"You're low on funds." Notifications…
Why are we walking? It's weird.
This is so different! What is happening?!
You almost forgot?
That's right.
Hey, we're off the Grid, but I still
think that the gameplay is glitchy. I can't tell
if it's the game or it's supposed
to be like this.
I literally can't tell. Honestly, the
graphics does not look that good.
What the fuck? Like the first game looked
better than this. Okay, you gotta hold to do super-jump.
Yeah, that worked.
I think I need more speed.
Okay.
We should get– How the fuck am I supposed to get up there?
"Hold while running to springboard".
Oh! Look at that shit.
Oh my god.
Here we go. Why is it glitch–
It's glitching like fucking crazy.
Look at this.
Here I was, just so excited to play
the game… And I gotta deal with this shit.
Please work, I would love to play this game right now.
Okay. Alright. It looks like it works.
Yeah!
Woo! Ow. Help.
I remember– Yeah, I'm here.
Noah?
Look, you can look at your own body.
It's so weird, like, I remember when the
first game came out, this was so uncommon.
I don't know why, it– It makes perfect sense to have…
Alright, I'll get in the old warehouse, Jesus…
Slide!
Okay, now it works fine!
Thank god. I'm so happy.
Woo!
Look at that!
Can we have, like, a– How do I dodge?
I know you have to click a button to roll…
Aw, shit, they got drones.
That actually makes perfect sense.
What's happening?
"KrugerSec Guardian"…
I remember these guys!
So you have to do, uh…
You can take them out or you can kill them.
Uh…
I would prefer not to kill him,
but I don't think I can.
There it is.
The fuck is this?
Ooh, la la…
Well, he's dead.
Oh!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
He just came.
Uh… Alright.
I know there's a button– Fuck!
I don't know the controls! Like, it won't tell me.
Thank you.
Oh, it feels good to be back, man.
♪ Makin' my way downtown ♪
Nice.
Oh, I'm a fuckin' idiot.
Okay.
Of course I can!
Now he tells me.
"We'll calibrate as I go."
You can cheat it. I remember this.
All these tiny tricks that you could do
to run faster, it's amazing.
I love that shit.
Like, this is a really speedrunner-ish
type of game.
Am I supposed to be paying attention to the story?
There's al– always so many different routes
you can go and shit. I like that.
There's no right way.
Well, I guess jumping on the fucking boxes…
Alright, I'll keep goin'.
There's literally no one chasing me, but I
suppose I'll keep goin'.
So not ev– everything is not painted, right?
This– This is just how, like, the runners see it?
There it is.
Lookin up the ghost's butthole. Thank you very much.
Ah, shit, they found me.
Kinda like how they had normal helicopters
in the first game. I don't know what the fuck this is.
O–
Oh! Nailed it!
Ah, man…
"Hold while falling to do a soft landing."
Okay.
What?
I thought I did it.
Hey! How ya doin', buddy?
And you're out.
In the first game you have to kinda
time the disarm.
It'd be a shame if they took that away.
That was a cool thing.
I sound so fucking nerdy this episode, I'm so sorry
We're off the Grid, guys.
We're not even gonna look where he went?
"Runner's Vision Your Beat display has finished calibrating. Pressing R will send a Runner's Vision pulse"…
Yeah.
This is what I was talking about, this is just how we see it.
Höp.
Yeah!
Woah! What the fuck!?
So you can even see how they run to kinda get a–
that seems unnecessary, but…
Come on, that wasn't even close, Faith.
Get outta here.
Whoop!
Alright!
This is cool, man.
Ah, I fucked up…
There it is.
I could take this route.
Nope. No, you can't. What the fuck is this?
You can climb anything.
Ay! Where am I? Ha ha ha ha…
Okay, so that's where we need to go. I like that.
So we can take literally shortcuts.
I wonder if I could make this jump?
Only one way to find out!
Nope.
Ha ha ha…
Alright, let's give that a go. Hey, buddy.
Dammit, I want the disarm thing! It was
so cool in the first game!
Whatever. Maybe they'll introduce it. I don't know!
Oh, god, just hearing myself talk about this game,
I'm like "what a fuckin loser".
Yeah! I like that move; it's cool.
There it is. Nice.
So we gotta do a wall jump here…
Nailed it. I am the best damn player.
Höp!
Nailed it! Best player.
Yeah! Ow.
Alright, here we go. Tricky jump.
Nailed it.
So good at games.
Already found it. Ha ha ha…
Woo! Yeah!
Jump the pipe!
Öp!
Yeah, super fast!
Oh!
Ah!
Ooh, soft landing.
What do we do here? Oh, I do the corners fast.
That's cool.
Oh, it feels so good to be back at this game!
I love it.
Wait, where am I going?
Hello, hello, hello.
We made it to the tower.
What a sassy-ass bitch!
About a year ago.
Oh, we'll see about that.
Fighting skills…
Alright!
Gimme some epic moves, man.
That funky music!
What the fuck is this?
"Puts enemies off balance"…
What if we do this?
Oh, okay, so you can knock them– Towards directions.
Got it.
And I can kick them off railings. Fantastic.
Boom!
Ay… Two birds with one…
Uh… Eh–
Yeah…
Bä!
That's cool, I can decide where to punch them.
That's always a good– That's always not–
Never– Not… A bad… Thing–
Shut up.
Whoop!
Yeah.
Jump attack!
Take that!
Excellent combo!
Where's the option to not hurt them?
'Cause I know that was like a super skillful thing if you
could beat the game without… Killing everyone.
Although, it is really cool when you get weapons
later in the game.
I'm not used to the controls. At all.
Another one.
Bitch!
I'll go down here.
Oh, slide attack.
Got it.
Jumpity jump!
"Attack from swing"…
Coming for you, bitch!
Thank you.
"Use your environment to deal high damage".
I mean, they die anyway.
Oh! Get wrecked, bitch!
Hell yeah, motherfucker!
"Combat Tutorial Mod Complete".
Fuck that.
I'm ready, Noah.
Here we go! Ah, thank god the rain stopped.
This is what I love about this game, its so fucking nice–
Oh my god, what the fuck was that!?
The fu– Hey buddy!
Alright, let's, uh… Let's just do the move.
U,h alright, look, I learned this one.
Hey, man, look at this move.
Oh, look at that!
You won't be standing up,
bitch!
Oh my god!
I actually spitted!
Oh, that's disgusting!
Oh my god, did you see that!?
Did you s– Ugh!
That was fuckin' gross as shit! What the fuck, man!?
Ha ha ha ha!
Ah, shit, I missed it.
Hey, buddy.
Jump attack!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Alright, here we go.
Did they say something about a drone? That's cool.
I'll play by the rules.
Look at this shit.
Hey, yo!
Goodbye, bitch!
Woo!
This way.
Åå!
Oh!
Yea– Ha ha ha ha!
I like it, I like i,! I like it!
I think we need some more speed.
So in the first game, you could sidestep jump.
Like… Let's see if you can do it.
This jump. You could do that to get more speed.
Yeah, it works!
I think it did, you get–
I don't fuckin' know, you have to be pretty fast.
Hey, buddy.
Do you like boxes?
Tha– He literally like fell over.
It looked like, y'know, when you're, uh–
You play with a kid and they punch you and
you pretend that you get hit.
That's what that looked like.
That was fuckin' pathetic, man.
Gotta–
Ha ha ha ha! They look so cl– Woah!
Holy shit! Man!
Dodge.
That was awesome!
Yeah!
Can we make it? Yeah.
Another thing I loved about this game when it gets
like, slower and you have to solve puzzles and shit.
This game gets tricky, I remember uh…
Fuck, I need to stop talkin' about the game.
I'm so f… Shut up, Pewds.
Nice ass, child.
You look cool.
Oh, no.
What's gonna happen?
I can't believe I spit by accident, that was disgusting.
Yeah, she couldn't have survived that.
What?
Nice move, Faith!
Woah! What a fuckin' leap of faith! Ha ha ha!
I see why th– she's called Faith now.
Ha ha ha! It just connected to me.
Fuck.
Aw, come on, did they take away
the bone-crushing sound?
Nice. Alright, let's get up here.
Nice.
Ooh…
Yas.
Oh, I like that!
Oh, look at that!
Look at that, I'm a pro, yo!
Shit.
Where was I supposed to go again?
Am I running in circles? No, I'm not.
Ay, what's good, everyone?
Look at this.
Ah!
Porn!
Use the elevator shaft.
You can look at your hands and shit, look at that.
Is it weird that this game makes me wanna do parkour?
Am I a loser?
Thank you.
Thank you veery mu– No, I appreciate that compliment.
You're always so nice to me.
Alright.
Nice.
Nice!
Ah, this is why I love this game.
It's so pretty.
Ah…
"Mirror's Edge™ Catalyst"…
Catalyst!
Alright, bros!
We're goin' on a new adventure!
This is gonna be awesome.
I'm so pumped for this game!
God dammit, they got flying cars and shit, don't they?
No, it's birds… It's birds.
Well!
Thank you so much for watching part one,
there's gonna be a new one tomorrow.
Please, if you want more,
leave a like, I really appreciate it and…
I'm just stoked to play more of this with you.
As always, thank you so much for watching.
If you want part two, lemme know.
And as always, stay awesome, bros!